-According to some polls,
you are the top choice
for Democratic voters
as far as who
they would like to see
as a vice presidential choice.
Is that something
that would interest you?
Have you had any conversations
about that?
-So, I have not talked
with people about it.
Look, I'm focused right no
on this crisis.
Last week, we were negotiating
the record $2 trillion bil
to try to support
healthcare workers
and try to support our economy
And now I'm pushing hard
on this oversight part of it
sending these letters, for
example, to Secretary Mnuchin.
That's just where my attention
is focused right now.
Frankly, I think
it would be presumptuous
for me to be doing
anything else.
-You haven't endorsed
a candidate yet.
And it certainly seems lik
your positions line up
more in lockstep
with Senator Sanders
than they do with Joe Biden.
Are you going to endorse,
or is this something
you're considering to wait on?
-You know, again,
I really just want to say,
right now, you know,
it's less about the politics
and much more about the crisis
that our country is in.
And I think that's really
where our focus has got to b
at this moment.
So, that's where I'm keeping
my attention right now.
We don't get to do any political
rallies at this moment anyway.
-You were asked about
gender's role in the campaig
after you dropped out,
and you said
that it was a trap question.
And the way you explained it
made a lot of sense to me.
What steps do we have to take to
make it not be a trap question
for candidates like yourself
that run as women
in this country?
-Well, I'll tell you what,
let me just explain
the trap to everyone.
It's, every time
you get asked the question
"Do you think you were
discriminated
as a woman in this race?
Do you think it was harder
for you because you're a woman?"
My answer is, look,
any way I answer that,
we got a problem.
If I say, "Yes, it was," then,
you know, you're just a whiner
And if I say "No, it wasn't,
at least half the population
will say,
"What planet
does that woman live on?"
So, you know, the best way
we can solve this is,
how about we elect a woman
President sometime soon?
And then we break that ceiling
and we don't have to ask
that question so often.
-I think that would be
a nice solution to that.
I have talked to you in the past
about Kate McKinnon's
portrayal of you.
You finally got a chance
to be on-stage with her
at "Saturday Night Live."
How was -- hopefully not the
last "Saturday Night Live" ever.
It is currently the last
"Saturday Night Live."
How was that experience for you?
-It was so much fun.
I mean, Kate McKinnon
is just wonderful.
She's such an incredibly
talented comedian.
But I have to tell,
what was even more fun is,
a couple of days later,
I was at the grocery store
at our Shaw's market.
And one of the workers
at the grocery store came up
this lady, and she looks and
sees me in the checkout line
And she says, "People,
we've got a celebrity here!"
And everybody looks around
And she says,
"It's Kate McKinnon!"
[ Both laugh ]
-I can't believe you didn'
count as a celebrity until that.
[ Both laugh ]
-Exactly.
She got it exactly right.
-I heard rumors,
and you can tell me
if it's true,
that between dress and air
which is one of the most fraught
times at "SNL,"
you actually made the case
for some of the lines
to not be cut from the sketch.
-I did. [ Laughs ]
I did, Including the one about
"I didn't die. I'm just
in the United States Senate.
[ Laughs ]
-There you go. I can tell you,
having worked there and having
been a writer on the show,
that the writers
who wrote those lines,
the fact that you
fought for them,
they will be fans
of yours forever.
-And I will be fans of theirs.